facing high queen hey queen hey queen
oh god like oh Aaron is okay there it is
where is it okay great um guys singer
and I mean like singer actress judge
mentor multi award winner and
self-confessed boss lady this year she
won a Grammy for Best Musical Theater
album for Broadway smash the color
purple gave an amazing performance as
motormouth Mabel in has Braille I've
released new music of her own and was a
judge and mentor on The Voice UK and of
course she won over to you Queen yes and
I won't read these this time I'll read
them you know she personifies the
Trailblazer of the year the title were
awarding her it is the one the only
Jennifer hunter oh thank you so much I
can't even believe I'm here and I don't
think my speech is gonna be as good as
that lesson okay I can't hang in I can't
lie but I can only speak from the heart
so I want to say thank you glamour for
this amazing honor and then to also say
just to be able to give women a platform
where we can be acknowledged we can be
appreciated and we can sit in rooms like
this and we see reflections of ourselves
and our greatness and what we can do as
women so with that that inspires me and
I'm again so happy to be here and then
also want to dedicate this award to the
UK to Manchester and I'm continually
praying for everybody here so thank you
so much